hi guys I got the request to do a video
on installing custom scenery and though
I didn't want to do it at first because
there are already many videos on this
subject I decided that I would do it and
actually make this a very detailed video
explaining many things involving the
process and not just saying okay you
need to install it here in here so what
I'd like to talk about first is
something that I haven't really seen
anybody talk about yet it's where you
actually get your custom scenery because
there are many ways you can get it and I
just want to kind of show you around the
many sites and things that I usually use
so my favorite thing to do is just to go
to the custom scenery Depot it's this
site over here custom scenery Depot calm
I will add the links to all the sites
that I'm going to in the description so
you can always check that out and this
is by far my favorite site pretty much
nearly everything I think is on this
site there are a couple of authors of
well creators of customs in Erie who
don't post it on this site but yeah
that's actually something that I like
about this the creator of a custom
scenery usually posts his own custom
scenery over here and this is a very
popular site as you can see the main
page kind of just shows of the the most
popular recently released sets so that's
always something to check out and when
you go to the downloads section over
here you can actually find everything
not just custom scenery but also all of
that other jazz but of course we'd like
to have some custom scenery so when you
go there you're going to get this window
and though this might be kind of
frustrating at first because there's so
many things and quite a few of them are
actually not something that you'd want
so I usually just go to search button
and then just turn on rollercoaster can
three custom scenery and let's say for
example that I am looking for shy guys
alpine village then I would just want to
look for an alpine village set and
please bear with me with my terrible
typing because I'm kind of typing in a
very weird fashion because this
pop-filter is in front of my arms and
there you go so now you get all of these
alpine village sets and that's this is
pretty much everything you need you can
download nearly every set from this site
we're going to look at while finding
custom scenery with Google later on and
you'll find that many of the custom
scenery links that you'll find on Google
are also referring to this site now if
you don't like this
system they've still got a different one
which is also very handy it's called the
CES list it's over here and if you click
on it you get this enormous well it's
not really the list yet so we'd like to
go to CSO which is which also stands for
custom scenery objects a more and more
common well abbreviation of a SCS but
you'll see many people using CSO as well
so if we go to there then you'll find
this list and it's pretty much it's
pretty much the alphabet and once you
click on a letter let's not say for
example B you get all of the sets that
people have submitted to this website
that start with a B now as you can see
this is a whole lot of sets this is
crazy you can't really find anything
with this so what I would usually do is
for example I'll I'll well let's take a
plain village again I like to find
alpine village so I'll click on the a
and then just press ctrl F to get that
Alpine out there and then as soon as we
do that you can find all of the Alpine
words within this file so there we go
that's all of the alpine village sets
and then if you go here you can find
well the content is always just a small
summary of what it is location is just
where it is the way you can find it in
game so that's very handy information
and there are pictures but more often
than they're not they are not actually
there or they're not working so that
doesn't really matter and then when you
go to the download you get referred back
to the download of the custom scenery
depot so it's essentially the same site
it just has a different way of kind of
working around it now something that
other people suggest that I am actually
not a fan of is using ICT go because as
you can see ICT go calm is this website
that has a forum but it also has a
download section now the problem that I
have with this is it allows everyone to
upload anything and the problem with
that is that more often than not you're
going to have people aren't the actual
creators of course some scenery who
submit custom scenery to the site I've
actually seen someone submit my
unfinished custom scenery sets to this
site without me actually knowing it so
that kind of happens it's somewhat
unorganized and it's not
moderate it very well if it's moderated
at all so I'm not a fan of it when it
comes to that but sometimes you'll be
able to find sets on this site that you
can find anywhere else so let's say for
example that I want alpine village again
I'm just going to look for Alpine and
just going to click on some scenery
normally all of these things are ticked
so if you only want custom scenery then
I'd say just D click all of those things
so let's search for downloads and see
what we get we don't even get anything
isn't that amazing where we turn
actually everything on there might just
not be a download for it on this website
as you can see there are plenty of other
things so it's probably not on this
website that's what I think so let's see
for example we steel jungle it should be
steel jungle iron there you go so
somebody actually did upload steel
jungle but there you go it's called mobi
steel jungle but it's uploaded under the
name of mooby's steel jungle over here
so this is well to better download so as
you can see it's quite unorganized but
sometimes you'll be able to find sets
that you can find elsewhere on this site
so if you really have no other choice
there you might still want to look at it
but I don't recommend it now the third
site is ICT dB they have a lot of
downloads of custom scenery the only
problem with this site is when they
started it they had the idea to make one
very handy and well just with a nice
layout site that everyone can use to
find anything in Rolla Co second three
the only problem with it it's kind of
outdated at the moment as you can see
the last thing they posted or it's not
really the last thing but yeah they kind
of ended the [ __ ] in 2012 so it's kind
of outdated when it comes to that
however most of the downloads still work
and you'll probably be able to find many
of the sets that you need over here and
I don't know if they've got alpine
village on this site they might just
have it though let me say you know
that's not too much on it usually I find
that this set is a bit better for CTRs
because it also has that stuff but
there's some custom scenery on this set
on this site as you can see now the last
site that I would want to talk about and
this is only for
or to custom cinema sets and the
basically sometimes you'll ask somebody
what a certain custom scenery set is and
it turns out that the custom scenery set
is just gone everywhere I've had that
multiple times like some custom scenery
sets have been on old sites but the
sites have disappeared or the download
links aren't working anymore in one way
or another but the thing is this is a
very old site but it's still on and most
of the downloads actually still working
so if you're looking for a very old site
that very old set that barely anyone has
any more than I say that this site is
pretty much your best bet I know that
I've had this one set which was called a
Siena's but pavement essentials and at
some weight go away I know I want you go
away okay
so thank you so at some point there
wasn't actually the pavement essentials
weren't actually on the custom scenery
Depot but they were still on this site
and I know that many sets on this site
are quite unique the decide to if you
really want to pick this stuff up it's
pretty old and it's somewhat updated but
sometimes it's really handy so that's
also something now the last thing of
course it's just Google if you really
can't find something it's always just a
good idea to google it so that's Google
shyguys alpine village and you've got
multiple sites and my video there I'm
sorry sorry about that so and as you as
you see you also find the custom scenery
Depot so it really seems like this is
the best place to get your custom
scenery and that's also what I'd say now
let's say for example that we want to
install the set so now we're going to
actually install things and yeah I'm
sorry about taking so long for this but
I want to explain absolutely everything
now you'll see that you get this kind of
file which is a zip file which most
Windows 7 computers will be able to open
on its own so we'll get into the set and
find all that stuff over here and it's
unnecessarily complicated and all that
but sometimes you'll get sets that don't
have that so let's say for example I
know that station Jim has those SATs
which are packed in a different kind of
compressive format so let's see that
I think it's this one yeah let me
download this okay so as you can see it
didn't actually download in a zip file
and this is a RAR file and you're not
able to open RAR files with windows if
you don't have a program to open it many
people use winrar which is actually a
program that you're supposed to be to
pay for but you're pretty easily well
you you can get around that without even
cracking it it's quite a stupid thing
but what I always like to use is a
program called zip 7-zip and it's a very
easy and small program it's free to
download so let me just get this here
you don't quite want to get the beta
it's ok to get it but it's just more
stable to not get the beta one and then
just download the dot exe downloader and
you'll go to SourceForge which is
something that's quite annoying and it's
yeah just in general
[ __ ] them but it's not that bad so we
get that download and we open that and
which is going to install 7-zip and let
them just do that and thankfully this
this because with most most free
programs they always go like ok you're
going to get this toolbar and you're
gonna get this malware and all that but
thankfully 7-zip doesn't do that all you
have to do is just let that thing
install itself then you're pretty much
done with that and as long as that thing
doesn't freeze you're pretty good to go
so let's go back to our damaged
downloads section over here no way I'm
completely lost
come on I mean let me go back to this
thing this thing ok so now we can open
this file and as you'll see it's very
similar to the shyguys alpine village
set in the way that it looks that you
get this followed and let me remove this
this isn't necessary
I need 7-zip so basically what you'll
get is a folder or two follows because
this shared folder is something that you
don't need to pay attention to with a
style common and a style unique ovl and
a either a may
a Mis misc or the name of the set folder
now basically this folder so that would
be the misc folder for this one and the
alpine village set for the for that one
contains all of the objects within the
set but this style dot common end style
dot unique actually contains the theme
that you need to open the set so
basically you need to go back one folder
and install that now what some people do
is they're going to go back and actually
extract this and then you'll get a
folder within a folder and then this
style common and style unique thing and
that's not something you want that's
when you're going to get errors in the
game a very common error in the game is
the no SVD for s ID or it's reversed I
always forget that and you can basically
avoid that by just installing this
folder instead of installing this and
then having a folder inside of that and
then the folder with the style that
common and styled unique so I'll show
how to install this with a zip file if
you're on Windows 7 and you can open the
file with that 7-zip all you need to do
is just copy it and go to Program Files
and if you're on a 64-bit computer
you're going to have to go to Program
Files x86 and then you're going to have
to go to atari roller coast icon 3 and
then to style themed and then you're
going to paste it in there so that's
that now I already have that so I don't
need to actually paste it but that's
what you basically need to do and if
you're inside 7-zip you're going to have
to say extract now my 7-zip is Dutch but
this little minus sign says extract and
you're going to browse and it's going to
be in the exact same manner it's just
going to be inside this little window
but you're going to go to the same place
gonna go to Program Files Atari voila
Coast again 3 & Style themed let me find
that yes thank you very much and they're
just going to extract it like that and
of course I've already got this so I
don't want to actually say yes to that
so that's basically how you install
custom scene resets and where you need
to find them so now let's look in game
and see what we've got
okay so roller coaster can three
is all loaded up now so let's look in
walls and actually see what we've got so
let's scroll down to shyguys alpine
village and there we go there is the
alpine village set and now you should be
able to open it without any errors and
without not being able to find it and
sometimes you will notice that not all
of the custom scenery sets are actually
in walls and it really depends on the
set most of the times the custom scenary
creators are so friendly to actually put
them in the corresponding and theme so
you'll actually find that many of the
sci-fi custom scenery sets are also in
the sci-fi theme as you can see so I've
got all these science fiction stuff that
is actually in the sci-fi theme and if I
go to spooky you'll also find that many
of station gems spooky sets are actually
in this theme as well and you'll also be
able to find that most of these sets
actually consist of pieces to build
buildings and if you go to objects most
of the custom scenery sets are actually
because some scenery sets that and
contain objects and obviously if you go
to foliage pretty much all of the
foliage sets are actually in foliage so
that's how that works and if you open
because some scenery you're pretty much
able to do with it whatever you can do
with in-game scenery you're able to
place it and do with it whatever you
want with with one major difference or a
couple at least usually in game sets are
only you can only place them on the grid
and you can kind of place these off grid
as well and these don't stack the way
in-game things work so you can actually
intersect them so yeah that's all there
is to this tutorial hope you've learned
something and enjoyed it if you have any
questions feel free to ask me in the
comment section bye